- [Ryan Yanchuleff] Thank you
for coming out this afternoon
for our session on Kiro.
We'll be talking about
how to build applications
and we're gonna be
building a live application
in front of you here this afternoon.
So I am Ryan Yanchuleff,
I'm one of our specialist
solutions architects here at AWS.
I'm part of the Next Generation
Developer Experience team.
So we work with customers who are looking
to roll out generative
AI development tools
inside of their organizations.
And with me, I have Ryan.
- [Ryan Bachman] And I am
also Ryan, Ryan Bachman,
same team, same responsibilities,
same everything that he just said.
As we get into the session,
who's done a code talk before?
Anybody?
Anyone done a code talk before?
Okay. These sessions are
really meant to be interactive.
So while we are gonna
be doing live coding,
I also encourage us to
engage, learn from each other.
I'll be walking around as
he's presenting and coding.
We'll have some dev time, ask questions.
I'll go ahead and amplify that question
and we can kind of talk about it, right?
Whatever you want to talk about, learn,
we're here to talk about agentic AI
or spec-driven development
as well with Kiro.
So yeah, let's just feel free,
share your opinions, share your thoughts.
I will be polling the
audience numerous times today.
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] Yeah,
we are going to be building
an application from scratch inside of Kiro
live on the screen.
And we're going to build an application
that you guys and gals recommend.
So Ryan's gonna poll the
audience here in just a minute,
and we're gonna take the
two or three best ideas
and we're gonna build them
live here on the screen.
We'll build the best
one live on the screen,
so, you know, be thinking
about that as we walk
through the next couple of slides here.
So before we dive into it,
wanna just kind of set the stage,
talk a little bit about what Kiro
is so that everybody's familiar with it.
It's a relatively new product
that we released this year,
and it just went general availability
about two weeks before today.
So with that, one of the
questions that we get asked a lot
is why did we build another tool?
There's a lot of them out there.
So why did we build another one?
And I think it's helpful
to kind of understand
where things have gone
and how they've evolved.
So if you go back a couple of years,
we started out with generative AI
that just did sort of general helping.
It was a glorified IntelliSense,
auto complete, simple chat
questions and interactions
and things like that.
And then more recently
we got into a situation
where we could do assistance.
We could say, "Hey, I want to go
and make a change to this function."
Or, "I want to go and debug
this particular log file."
Or, "Help me out with this thing."
Very specific tasks that we could, again,
ask the generative AI tools
to go in and help us with.
And then in the current age,
we have what we call agents,
which is where I take
more complex problems.
I say, "Here's what I want to do,
here's what I want to build.
I wanna build an application.
I want to add a new feature
to my existing application.
I wanna modernize this
part of my application.
I wanna migrate this
piece of application code
and I need you to help me out with that."
And that involves
multiple different steps.
"I've gotta run things
on the command line.
I've gotta talk to third-party tools.
I've got to generate code.
I've gotta modify existing code."
And we call this agentic development.
The term "agentic" gets overloaded a lot.
So I think it's helpful
to kind of understand
what we mean when we say that.
So the promise here was
that we get autonomy.
We could all go sit on the beach
while we let the generative AI tools
go and write code for us.
We get more collaboration.
We have a back and forth conversation
with this generative AI tool
and we chat along and we tell funny jokes
and we get work done,
just like you do with
your other coworkers.
And then we, of course,
get high-quality code.
Nobody's producing junk when we do this
'cause we're all professionals.
And so this is the promise.
The challenge though, that we
saw with customers starting
to use these tools in their
production environments
centered around three major things.
And it was these three major things
that we set out to solve
for when we built Kiro.
And these three things really
are laid out here for you on the screen.
The first one and the biggest
one is how do you scale?
So it's great when I
wanna build Tic-Tac-Toe
and I'm just one developer in a corner
hacking out some code.
But when I have an existing
production application
with 1.2 million lines of
code and I've got a team
of 150 developers who
are all working together,
this becomes really important
because I need my LLM
to be able to understand all that code.
I need it to be able to
understand that code consistently.
And I need it to be able
to produce similar results
for all 150 developers along the way.
It does me no good if the
non-deterministic nature
of the LLMs creates working solutions
for all 150 developers,
but it does so in very incompatible ways,
which is possible when you think about
the non-deterministic
aspects of generative AI.
So how do we do this at scale?
How do we solve for
large development teams
and how do we solve for
large existing code bases?
The other piece is the idea of control.
We talked about, in the previous slide,
about this true collaboration concept,
but that's not really what
we have in generative AI.
What we have in generative
AI is we take this prompt
that we kind of concoct and
and throw into the chat box,
we throw it over the wall and
we say, "Make me something."
And it goes off and it
writes a 1,000 lines of code
and it says, "I made you something."
And then it hands it to you
and hopefully it did it right.
But more than likely what happened
is that it got to a lot of
different decision points,
a lot of details that you
left out of your prompt
that it now has to go
and fill in the blanks.
And maybe it got it right,
maybe it chose the option
you would've chosen,
maybe it didn't, but now it's
up to you to figure that out.
And now you've got a 1,000 lines of code
that you've gotta go
and figure it out with.
And then the last piece
is when you take those
two factors together,
both of those negatively impact
the overall quality of the code.
What you're getting is code
that you don't really want.
It doesn't really do
what you wanted it to do,
and it doesn't really do it
the way you wanted it to do.
And it does it differently
for all the different
developers on your team,
which is not helpful.
So what we created for Kiro
and what we tightly
integrated into the solution
is something that we call
spec-driven development.
And it's a return back to first principles
of software development.
We don't bring a team of
developers into a room,
write four bullet points on a whiteboard,
and say, "Guys, we'll check
in on you in six months.
Let us know how it goes."
That would be chaos, and for good reason.
What we do is we step back and we say,
"All right, what are the requirements?
Let's detail those.
Let's bring in our stakeholders,
let's bring in all the key
players and lay that out."
Then we say, "All right, well
these are the requirements.
How are we gonna build this?"
And we build a design document and we say,
"What are all of the
different design specs
and the technical details?"
And we lay all of those out
and we bring in all the stakeholders.
And then we say,
"All right, well, what
is the project plan?"
We build one of those fun Gantt charts
with all of the different
tasks that we can do
in parallel and in serial
and we lay those things out.
And then once we have those,
then we bring the team
of developers in the room
and we say, "Here's what you're building.
Here's how you're building it.
And here's all the different
tasks that you need to do."
And we use those to go off
and actually do the implementation.
And that's how we solve for this problem
of building at scale.
So what spec-driven development does
is it takes generative AI and
it applies the same model.
It says, "Give me your
prompt that you concocted,
that's missing a lot of details,
and instead of going off and
writing a 1,000 lines of code,
I'm gonna go and I'm gonna
generate a requirements document.
And then I'm gonna
generate a design document.
generate a project plan.
And you're gonna have the opportunity
to review all those things.
'cause they're just text documents.
And then when you're
happy with all of those,
then we'll start building."
And whether it's just you
on a greenfield application,
like what we're gonna do here in a moment,
or whether you've got a
team of a 100 developers
and hundreds of thousands
of lines of code,
we're gonna get very similar results
because we're working
with the same context.
We're working with the same details,
and we've had a chance in advance
to review all of the different details
that might have gotten
left out from your prompt.
And we can fill in the blanks
and we can validate them
all and then we can move on.
And so that's what
spec-driven development is,
and that's really what makes Kiro unique.
So if you could build an application
and take advantage of that, how
would you go about doing it?
And so this is where
we're gonna switch over
and we're gonna switch
to a live coding demo.
And so I'm gonna need some ideas
because I've got a blank, empty screen
and I need something to build.
- [Ryan Bachman] Yep.
Anybody that's been to
like an improv show,
I'm gonna try this out.
Like, you know, you shout
out like random ideas
and then we're gonna maybe
combine a couple or two.
So this is where we need the audience.
So, like, don't raise your
hand, just like yell out-
- Fitness app.
- What's that?
- A fitness app.
- Alright, a fitness app.
Anyone else?
- [Audience Member] That
focuses on the trainer.
- [Ryan Bachman] Fitness app
that focuses on the trainer.
- [Audience Member] AWS event app.
- AWS what now?
- Event app.
Event manager. That's my app.
- Is that your-
- I came up with that app.
- Any other-
- That's what I normally do
in my demos.
- [Ryan Bachman] I don't know
how to combine those two.
- [Audience Member] Virtual concierge.
- [Ryan Bachman] Virtual concierge?
- For hotels
- Oh, hotel.
- There you go.
- All right.
So we got a fitness app, concierge app,
and I don't know how to
combine all three of those.
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] All right, let's see.
Let's see what we can come up with here.
- [Ryan Bachman] How
about a fitness app for-
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] "I want
to build a web application
to manage my fitness-"
- [Audience Member] Track
your steps through AWS.
- There you go.
- "Activities and determine
if I actually did them
and how many calories
I burned in the process."
- Perfect.
- Alright, we have 40 minutes.
So I'm simplifying this down a little bit.
But, okay, so here's my prompt.
If you look at that prompt,
you can tell pretty quickly right away
that there's a lot of detail missing here.
I have specified that I
want a web application,
I have not specified what I want it to be.
Could be React, could be
Python, could be .NET,
could be some esoteric
language from 40 years ago.
We haven't really defined that.
We haven't specified a
lot of things in here
like do we want authentication?
That's probably a good idea
for a personal fitness app.
We haven't specified what
a lot of the features are.
We haven't defined whether
we want a full stack app
with a data layer and a business
layer and a front layer,
or whether we want to
build this all together
like a Next.js app, for instance.
We haven't said if we
want it to be mobile.
Well, actually we did.
We said we wanted it to
be a web application,
so we specified that.
But you get the point.
There are a lot of details here.
And in Kiro, I have the ability to switch
between two different modes.
So if I were to put this into Vibe mode,
which is what you'd get from a traditional
generative AI tool, and
I were to hit "Go" here,
it would go off and it would
immediately start building.
And what would it start building?
Well, it would figure out some strategy
to build a web application.
It might pick React, it might pick Python,
it might pick something else.
And if there were five
of us up here on stage,
it might pick something
different for each one of us
because generative AI, by
definition, is non-deterministic,
so we're not guaranteed the same results.
But I'm gonna put it into Spec mode
and I'm gonna kick this off.
And so what's gonna
happen now is that Kiro,
instead of going off and
actually writing the code,
is it's going to start
generating what we call a spec.
And a spec here is going
to define what it is
that we wanna build before we
actually start building it.
And so we're gonna let
this run in real-time
to kind of give you a
sense of how much time
this actually takes.
The spoiler alert, it
doesn't take very long,
assuming that our network holds up here.
And so it's going to create
for us a requirements document.
And you can see here,
it's opened it up for me on the screen.
And so I've got my requirements
document on the screen here.
And this requirements document starts out
with a high-level introduction.
So it's given me kind of a
general summary of what I put in.
I wrote one sentence
into the prompt box here.
I've gotten a paragraph of
details that are laid out.
I've also gotten a glossary of terms
so that we are clear on
what we're talking about.
It's laid out a lot of different details
like what's a user?
What's an activity?
What kind of activity types are there?
How do we calculate calorie consumption?
How do we deal with the activity logs?
All of these different
things here are laid out.
These are all important things
if I'm gonna go and build this application
that I didn't specify
in my original prompt.
And then we're gonna get
into the meat of this,
which is the requirements themselves.
So each requirement is
gonna have a user story
and it's gonna have a set
of acceptance criteria.
And so the user story combined
with the acceptance criteria
is going to detail all of the
different things that I want.
And you can see here that it came up
with seven requirements,
which is not bad considering
that I gave it one sentence.
Now, is that enough requirements
to build a full fledged web application
for fitness tracking with auth
and all of those other details?
Probably not.
But it does get us
quite a bit farther down
the road than we would've been
if we had just taken this prompt
and thrown it over the wall.
And one of the things that's important
to understand about specs
is that they're not really designed
to be used to write an
entire operating system.
You want to use something like a spec
to do feature development.
So our application here is
going to evolve over time.
There are going to be things
that we want to add to it.
There are gonna be things as
we show off our initial MVP
to our stakeholders.
There are gonna be things
that they're gonna say,
"Well, this is really cool,
but I want to add this thing.
This is really cool, but
I wanna change this piece.
I hate this thing.
I can't believe you built this."
And we're gonna go a couple
different routes here
and we're gonna be able
to evolve as we go.
So we've got our user stories here
and they follow a specific format.
They follow what we call EARS.
It's an industry standard
for writing requirements
is it's Easy Accessible
Requirements System Spec,
something like that.
I never remember what
that acronym stands for,
but it follows that key system,
which is that it creates a user story
and then it creates acceptance criteria.
And so what we can do now is we can say,
"All right, let's review this.
Do we like this?
Does it capture the things that we want?
Did we think of something
else in the five minutes
that it took to create this document
that we want to add to this?"
And so we can evaluate and iterate on this
and we can make adjustments.
For the sake of time, I'm
gonna leave it here as it is.
But it says here, like,
"As a user, I want to create
and manage fitness activities."
That's a good start.
That kind of aligns with
the prompt that I have here
so that I can plan and
track my exercise routines.
Cool.
"I want to mark the
activities as completed
with their actual duration,
so that I can track what
I actually accomplished."
And you can see here that each
one has acceptance criteria.
So when a user creates a new activity,
the application should store
that activity with the details,
with the type, with the planned duration,
with the planned date,
all of that information
should get tracked.
Maybe I want to add
another attribute there,
maybe you want to track location as well.
And so now is my
opportunity to come in here
and make an adjustment.
And I can say I want to
add location to my data
that's being stored.
All I'm doing here is
modifying a markdown file.
So once I'm happy with the requirements,
I move on to the design phase.
And I say, "All right,
well, this is great,
but now I wanna know how am I
actually going to build this?
What language am I gonna write it in?
What libraries am I gonna use?
What am I gonna do for authentication?
How am I gonna handle error handling?
What am I gonna do for testing?"
All of these different details
need to be captured here.
And so we gave it no details
except for a web application.
So we're all gonna find out together
what this thing actually decides to build
and how it decides to build it.
And this is gonna be
our opportunity to say,
"No. I don't wanna build it with Python,
I want to build it with React.
I don't wanna build it with React,
I want to build it with Go.
I want to build it with a SQL database.
I don't wanna build it
with a SQL database.
I want to build it with NoSQL databases."
This is my opportunity to
correct for all of these things.
Because at this point, if we, again,
just threw this over the
wall with vibe coding,
the LLM would make
those decisions for you.
It would say, "You didn't tell me
what kind of database you wanted.
I feel like SQL today,
I'm going that route."
And if you wanted NoSQL,
you're out of luck.
You're gonna have to go back
and rebuild that code after the fact.
And so that creates
complications and it takes time
to evaluate for all of those things.
So at this point, we're
gonna get an evaluation.
And you can see here one of the things
that it's doing is it's saying
that it's formalizing the requirements
for correctness properties.
What this is, so Kiro has a feature in it
called property-based testing.
And property-based testing
is a really fancy term
for essentially testing with edge cases.
But it's going to evaluate my requirements
and it's going to say,
what are the things that
need to be checked for?
How am I going to check for them?
And not just the happy path,
but what are all the edge cases?
You say that you want to know
what your planned duration
is for your activity.
Well, what happens if you enter a bunch
of letters into that field?
What's it gonna do?
Is it gonna give you an error?
Is it gonna crash?
Is it gonna blow up?
How's it gonna handle that?
So that's just one example.
But you can see here that it's looking
at the different prompts there
or the different
requirements and it's saying,
"All right, well, what do we need to do
to test for all of that?"
And so when we go now and we
look at the design document,
what we have here is
another summary at the top
with all of these details.
We have more architecture.
So we have a foundation layer,
we have a business layer,
we have a data access layer,
we have our browser's local
storage, we have a tech stack.
It looks like it's using
React with TypeScript here.
That's what it's settled on.
It's gonna use the React context
API for state management,
it's gonna use Tailwind for my UI.
So a lot of different things
here are being specified.
And, again, if I don't
like any of those things,
it's pretty simple.
I just go in and modify
this document here,
and I'm good to go.
So it's gonna lay out, again,
the stack for all of the
different models that I have.
We're gonna get into the data layer,
we're gonna get into the
correctness properties
and all of the different ways
in which we're gonna do that.
So what happens if I have a planned and...
Stop that.
What happens if we have a
planned and actual duration?
Do they both get preserved?
So how are we gonna calculate that?
What are we gonna do for
triggering the calorie calculation?
A whole lot of different details there.
Then we get into error
handling, input validation.
We get into business logic errors.
We get into testing
strategies, including employing
all of those different
property-based tests
that we outlined above.
What do we do for unit testing
and integration and test execution?
So there's a lot of detail
here that's captured.
You got some questions over here?
- Go ahead.
- So the question
was two things.
The MCP servers, is that the
default or did you add those?
I saw agent steering.
What is that?
- Okay.
So just, I mean, for the room too,
so the questions are we
have some MCP servers
that are configured, you
can see in this video
and then also agent steering.
What is agent steering?
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] Yeah. So
the MCP servers I installed.
So by default Kiro doesn't come installed
with any MCP servers.
It has support though
for local MCP servers
and for remote MCP servers.
So you can go through the
remote MCP server flow,
you can do OAuth to connect
to your remote MCP servers
if you want to do that.
Or you can install local MCP servers
and you can configure them.
I have these installed at the user level,
which means that they work
for all the different
projects that I open.
You can also install MCP
servers at the project level,
so they're only relevant
to the specific project.
So these MCP servers here
happen to be installed
locally on my machine.
I don't know that we're
necessarily gonna use them
over the course of our demo here,
but you can install whatever you want.
They don't come pre-installed.
Now the question about agent steering.
So over here on the left hand side,
this is my Kiro panel here
on the left hand side.
I get to it by clicking
on the little ghost here.
Kiro by default is a a VS Code fork.
So if you're looking at this going,
"This looks pretty familiar,"
it's because it's a VS Code fork.
And so a lot of the UI and elements here
are gonna be very familiar to you.
But there's a section here at the bottom
with the little ghost
that brings up the details
that are unique to Kiro.
And you can see here at the top,
the spec that we're
working on is listed here.
And so I can see the
spec that I have here.
I can create as many specs as I want.
So I'm not limited to one spec.
I don't have to try and build
my entire project in one go.
I can create multiple different specs
and I can track them all as I go along.
We'll finish this one
out here in a moment.
But down here I have Agent Steering.
So what is Agent Steering?
Well, if you've used other
generative AI tools before,
you're familiar with the idea of context,
or you're familiar with the idea of rules.
So in Q Developer, for instance,
we have the idea of rules.
What a rule is, is essentially
just a piece of context
that sort of provides guidelines
for the LLM to follow.
Whenever you document or
whenever you write a function,
I want you to include a comment block
that looks like you know,
X, Y, Z at the top of it.
And so that's a rule, I want
Kiro to to do that for me.
Steering documents though,
and particularly this button
called Generate Steering Documents,
deal with one of the challenges
that we talked about in
the slide presentation,
which is how do I deal with projects
that have existing code?
How do I deal with a project
that has hundreds of
thousands of lines of code?
Well, in order to do
that, what I need to do
is I need to document that somehow,
I need to create some context around it,
I need to summarize it,
and I need to make that
available to the LLM
in the form of rules or
context or something like that.
And so what Generate
Steering Documents does
is that the first time I...
Or whenever I open up a
new code base in Kiro,
and by "new" here, I mean new to Kiro.
So maybe I've been working
on this project for 10 years,
but I'm gonna open it up in
Kiro and I'm gonna go down
and I'm gonna hit that Generate
Steering Documents button.
And what it's gonna do for me
is it's going to reverse
analyze that code for me.
So it's gonna go through
all of that source code
and it's going to summarize it for me.
and it's gonna say, "All
right, here are the details
that I need to be aware of when you ask me
to make a change to this code."
And so it's going to create
a file called product.
And the product file is a natural language
summary of the code.
It's a layout of what is this code doing
that I as as a reader, as a human,
could quickly pull up and say,
"All right, give me a summary
of what this 800,000 line
code project is doing,"
and I can read through that.
Then it's gonna build a tech file.
And the tech file is really gonna mirror
what our design document
file looks like here.
It's gonna be the tech stack.
What language is it written in?
What libraries is it using?
What's its strategy for error handling?
What's its strategy for testing?
What are the commands necessary
to boot the dev server?
What's the command necessary
to run the test suite?
All of those different things
are gonna get captured in the tech file.
And then it's gonna build the...
I'm blanking on the last name.
The product file, I
think is the last file,
is essentially the roadmap.
And so the roadmap file is gonna lay out,
here's the directory
structure of this project,
here's all of the different
directories, here's the code,
the files that are in
each of these directories.
Here's what's relevant about
each of these directories
in each of these files.
Here's the major classes and modules
and elements inside of these.
And equally as important,
if I ask you to make a change
to this particular module,
what's the blast radius?
So I ask you to make a change
to the authentication component
in my 800,000 line project.
If I go in and modify that,
how many other things in this project
are gonna be impacted by that change?
And in order to know the answer to that,
I need to know what the
spiderweb looks like
of how these different modules
interact with each other.
And so Kiro is gonna capture
all of that information for me
in the form of these three steering files.
And it's gonna do that
for me automatically
when I press that button.
But that steering directory is open-ended,
so I can add whatever other
things I want to add there.
So if I have a rule about how
I do software development,
I can generate that and add
it to the steering directory.
If I have a rule about...
Or if I have information
about a third-party API that I talk to
and I want to be able to be aware of that,
I want the LLM to understand
how do I use that API,
what does it do, how does it work?
I can document that and add
it to the steering directory.
And all of these files they live,
if we go back to the File Explorer,
they live inside of this .kiro directory
at the root of my project.
So you can see here, we're
starting out from scratch.
I don't have anything
in my File Explorer yet
except the specs that I created.
But as we start generating out more code,
this will all get captured
in here as we go along.
So does that answer your question?
- Yes. Thank you.
- Perfect.
- [Ryan Bachman] There's a question.
- [Audience Member] Yeah. So you mentioned
that we're not gonna
build an OS ever in life
in this sort of like
single prompt fashion,
which like from a process
perspective probably makes sense,
small increments and like a human needs
to also understand the
instrument they're working on.
Like technical limits.
We are blurting out a lot of context.
Is there going to be a technical limit?
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] Yeah.
So the question there is,
is there a technical context limit
that we need to be aware of?
And just like every LLM
there are context...
There's a context window that applies.
Kiro has a 200,000 character
context window at the moment.
- [Ryan Bachman] Token.
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] Yeah, token.
Sorry, what did I say, "character"?
- Character.
- Sorry. Token window.
We have some plans to
release bigger token windows.
As the models are evolving, the
token windows are expanding.
And so the product is kind
of evolving along with that.
If you get to a point where
your token window is full,
Kiro will ask you if you want to compact
your current session down
and start with, you know,
essentially reset your context window.
But one of the things about using specs
and using them with steering documents,
to the question that was asked earlier,
is that the combination of steering files
and spec files is a really
powerful combination
in the sense that all of this information
is already documented, largely,
in these markdown files.
So if I need to reset my session,
if I want to go on vacation
and come back on Monday,
I can do that and I
haven't lost a whole lot
because I'm detailing everything
here in these static files
and I can share these
files across the team.
So if somebody else needs to come in
and pick up where I left off
and do it from their own machine,
we don't need to worry about transferring
the session details because we've captured
all of the major important
points in these markdown files.
And so that's a big part
of why we're doing this
is because, again, we want
to work on collaboration.
We wanna be able to make
sure that every member
of the team is working
with the same context
and moving in the same direction
so that we cut out all of those variables.
So to keep things moving here,
I'm gonna move from
the design document now
and I'm gonna move on to
the implementation plan.
And while it's doing that,
if we have more questions, I
can certainly answer those.
- [Audience Member]
Yeah. I have a question.
So let's say we have team
where we have business
analysts that use Jira
to enter the spec and that.
- [Ryan Bachman] So the question is
how does this interact
with something like Jira
for like product management
and stuff like that?
Like, what's the interaction look like?
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] Yeah.
So as an organization,
my product managers are writing
their user stories in Jira,
and I want to be able to use
spectrum and development,
but I don't want to create
multiple sources of truth.
I don't want to take what's in Jira
and replicate it into my repo
and then have to deal with drift
and the potential of
things splitting apart.
And so the way in which you
solve for that is twofold.
One, you can install an MCP server.
So I can install the Jira MCP server
and I can integrate that
with my Jira project.
I can enter my credentials,
I can use a remote MCP
server, I can use a local one.
And I can enter the details
for my Jira project.
And then in the prompt here I can say,
"Hey, go get the user story ABC."
Or "Go get the user story
for adding the authentication module
to my application and poll that in."
And so what that does is it goes in,
it gets the information from Jira
and it polls that information in
and it reads that information
and it uses that to create the spec.
And so that's how I bridge
that gap from Kiro to Jira.
But that doesn't necessarily
entirely solve my problem,
it does get me access to that information.
It helps me build the spec
so I don't have to write
or copy paste all that
information into the prompt block.
But what happens if I make a change
to the design document or what
happens if I make a change
to the requirements document?
I say, "I want to tweak
one of these user stories."
Or, "I wanna make an adjustment
to one of these acceptance criteria."
I want to be able to
reflect that information
back into Jira so that my
data is staying in sync
so that I'm not creating
that drift situation.
And the way in which I do that
is using the last feature of Kiro
that we haven't talked about
yet, which is Agent Hooks.
And so what Agent Hooks are,
and I'll create one for
you here in a moment.
But what an a what an Agent hook is
is essentially an event-driven prompt.
So I take a prompt and my
prompt in this case would be,
"Whenever there's a change
to my requirements document,
I want you to summarize that change
and reflect it back to the
appropriate user story in Jira.
And I want you to run
this prompt automatically
whenever there's a change
to a requirements.md file.
So whenever you detect a file save event
on a requirements.md file,
summarize the change and push it back
to the appropriate Jira user story."
And so what this does now
is it creates a circular feedback loop.
So in the prompt I say,
"Go get the details
for the user story
related to my auth module
and poll that in and
generate the spec for it."
And then when I go and I make a change
to one of the acceptance
criteria in that spec,
my Agent Hook says,
"I detect you made a file save event
in your requirements document.
I'm gonna go and summarize that
and push that change back to Jira."
And that's all happening,
that connection there is
happening via the MCP server.
The MCP server doesn't just
allow me to read information,
it also allows me to write,
assuming I have the correct
permissions to do so.
And then it summarizes
it and it pushes it back.
And so now I have my user
stories are staying in sync
with my third-party tools.
So things like Jira can
be managed that way.
A lot of companies have
their design standards
or their software development standards
documented in something like Confluence.
They have an internal Wiki
or they have a SharePoint
server that lays out
how we do design, how we
do software development,
how we do all of those things.
And we can solve for that as well
with an MCP server that connects to that.
And then a steering file that says,
"Hey, whenever you
generate a design document,
make sure you go and refer
to our design standards
or our architecture standards
available at this MCP server
and use that information
so that you're not just
inventing some standard
for how you want me
to do software development.
Use the standards that
I've already established."
So that's how you would go about
kind of creating that feedback loop.
So we can see here now that
we've created our requirements,
we've created our design,
and now we've created our task list.
So our task list here is
essentially the project plan.
What are the things that I need to do
to go and implement these requirements
to this particular design standard?
And what Kiro comes back
with is it comes back
with this list of things
that need to be implemented,
and it's fairly exhaustive.
We have, let's see, 17,
18 tasks in this list.
And you can see that some
of them are grayed out,
some of them are bold and
some of them are grayed out.
And some of our tasks have sub tasks,
like task two has a task
2.1 and a 2.2 and a 2.3.
Some of them are grayed out.
What that means is that some
of these tasks are optional.
So Kiro's gonna make a
distinction here for me now
and it's gonna say,
"All right, well are you building an MVP.
Do you just want something quick and dirty
that you can kind of test out
and see what it looks like?
Or are you building a
production grade application?
In which case we need
to make sure we cover
all the bells and whistles?"
And so it's gonna ask me
here in the execution log,
"Which one are you making?
Are you making a quick MVP?
Or are you making a
comprehensive production app?"
Since we're pressed on time here,
I'm gonna say we're gonna make a MVP,
and I'm gonna leave those things optional.
And, really, those
tasks are around testing
and they're around documentation.
Our quick and dirty MVP application here
doesn't need a robust unit testing
and documentation strategy for it.
We just want something
that we can test out
and give it a try.
And if we look at these
individual tasks here now,
we can see that each task
has a checkbox next to it
that's gonna track our progress.
It's gonna tell us, "Is this task done?
Is it in progress?
Has it not been started yet?"
It's gonna lay out some of the details
that that task involves.
And then in blue there at the
bottom, it's going to say,
"Well, which of the
requirements are we fulfilling
by doing these particular tasks?"
So we're gonna get some traceability here
from the requirements to
the actual implementation.
So the first task here has
a button at the top of it
that says "Start Task."
And when I click that "Start Task" button,
it's going to go now
and it's going to switch
from Spec mode and it's
gonna switch into Vibe mode.
So when I click the "Start Task" button,
it's actually gonna go
and it's gonna start
actually producing the
code to implement this.
So this is gonna involve running commands,
it's going to need to
be able to set up React,
it's gonna need to be able
to configure TypeScript,
it's gonna have to
install the dependencies.
And you can see here now
that it's gonna get started on that.
So it's going to start out
by running the create vite command,
and it's gonna ask me for
my permission to do so,
'cause it's about to run a
command on my command line,
so it's gonna make some
changes to my local code
or to my local environment,
and I'm gonna have to approve this.
And so I can either accept this command,
I can add this command to
a trusted list of commands,
essentially saying, "I'll
give you permission to this
and don't ask me about this again.
So the next time you come across a command
that looks like this, go
and do it automatically,
don't ask me."
I can reject the command or
I can modify the command.
So here, to keep this simple,
we're gonna go ahead and
tell it to run the command.
And we can see right here
it ran into a problem.
I have Node installed.
Why is it not...
All right. In its effort
to be helpful here,
it's gonna try and figure out
how to do this automatically
without the fact that
I have Node installed.
We're gonna let this run
and we'll see how it goes.
But essentially what it's gonna do here
is it's going to kick off and you can see
that it's running in the terminal
window here at the bottom.
And it's going to start to generate
the files that are necessary.
So it's creating the vite config file,
it's creating the TypeScript config file,
it's creating a git ignore
file and the package.json
and all of the different
things that are necessary here.
So it's creating our main file,
our app.tsx file, our index.
So it's going to go through and it's going
to create the structure
for my application.
And if we switch over to
the File Explorer here,
we can see that it is generating
all of the different files
in our repository here.
So we're getting all of
these things built out for us
as it goes along.
And we'll figure out why
it can't find Node here in a moment.
But it's gonna go through this.
And you can see in the task list here
that it marks this as task in progress.
And we've got a little
hash here in the checkbox
denoting the fact that
this is in progress.
And we can view the changes here
that are happening in a git diff.
So if I click on this,
I can see all the different
files that are being modified
and the changes that
are being made to them.
And since we're starting
everything from scratch,
this is not gonna be a
particularly exciting diff
to look at, but you can see
here exactly what's happening.
And when it finishes,
we'll be able to look at
the execution log as well.
So now you can see that
the task is completed,
we can view the changes and
we can view the execution log,
which means we can come
back and we can see
what exactly happened
in the execution log,
what commands did it run,
and what were the results
of those commands.
Notably, we'll figure
out that surprisingly,
I don't have Node installed on my machine,
and the issue that that created.
And so it works through that.
At the end of this too,
it also tells me how many credits it used,
and how much time it took to run.
So this particular command,
or this particular task
took 2.3 credits, you'll
note the decimal there.
Credits can be consumed
in partial fractions.
So it's not going to charge
me for three credits,
it's gonna charge me for 2.3 credits
rather than rounding up.
And it took two minutes
and 59 seconds to complete.
And so we've got our task here.
And so the task now,
if we come back to the File Explorer,
these files are captured in the repo.
So now I can go and I can do a git commit
and I can check this
code into my repository
and I can say, "All
right, here are the specs
that I'm working from."
And so if I have multiple
developers, I can say,
"All right, well, I want this
developer to do task one,
and I want this developer to do task two,
and I want this developer
to do task three."
And I can divvy out the workload,
but they're all working from
the same requirements document
and the same design document
and the same task list.
So we're all moving in the same direction.
And if we had an existing code base here,
we could say they're all working
from the same steering documents as well.
So they all have the same understanding
of that core code base.
We're not relying on three
different inferences of the LLM
to draw the same conclusions
about that existing code.
It's all happening and it's documented
and it's shared across the team.
So we get that collaborative nature
that we were talking about.
Now somebody asked about what
do we do with Agent Hooks?
And so with an agent hook,
I can come in here and I can say,
"All right, I'm gonna
create an agent hook."
I'm gonna say, "Whenever a change is made
to a requirements.md file,
summarize the changes
and reflect them back
to the associated Jira user story."
And I'm gonna kick this off.
And what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna tell Kiro
to go and create a hook that does this.
Now I specified what
I want the hook to do.
I want it to summarize changes
and reflect them back to Jira.
And I told it what files I care about,
namely the requirements.md file.
It's gonna go off and it's
gonna do the rest here.
(audience laughing)
- [Audience Member] Looks great.
- [Ryan Bachman] Looks good.
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] That looks-
- [Audience Member] Looks accurate.
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] I love live demos.
- [Ryan Bachman] Obfuscated code.
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] So we can
see here in the hook panel,
it's created a hook here with the title,
"Requirements to Jira Sync."
It's created a description.
This is gonna monitor
the requirements.md files
and it's going to automatically
summarize those changes
and reflect them back to
the associated Jira story.
It's going to look for a file save event.
There's a couple of
different options in here.
I've got File Created, File Saved,
File Deleted, or a manual trigger.
Essentially that's just a saved prompt.
A manual hook is essentially
just a saved prompt
that I can run whenever
I want to kick it off.
It's gonna tell me the
file paths to look for.
It's gonna look for anything
that's called requirements.md.
I could tell it to look for any file
in a particular directory.
I could add multiple different things
that I want it to look for.
And then we get the actual prompt itself.
This is the prompt that it generated
based on that input that I gave it.
So a requirements.md
file has been modified,
please analyze the changes,
summarize the changes in
clear and concise way,
identify the associated Jira story,
and then push the changes
up to that Jira story
when you're done.
And so we've gotten now an Agent Hook.
And just like my specs
and my steering files,
these hooks get stored inside
of this .kiro directory,
so I've got my hooks here as well.
What that means now is that all the users
on the team have the same hooks.
All the developers now
have the same specs,
they have the same steering
files, they have the same hooks.
And so everybody is working
from the same set of information.
And this is how we
solve for, again, scale.
It's how we solve for collaboration
and it's how we solve for visibility
into the actual
understanding of what the LLM
is going to do.
So how is it going to behave?
What are the things that
it's going to perform?
And how is it going to go about
and actually perform them?
Wanna open it up for some more questions?
- [Ryan Bachman] Yeah, yeah, we got-
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] We are unfortunately
not going to have enough
time to actually build
this entire application
in the next 15 minutes.
And Kiro is spitting a little
bit of gibberish here anyway.
- [Audience Member]
Deterministic this process is
because it has to be repeatable, right?
For everybody?
- [Ryan Bachman] Yeah. So the question is
how deterministic is this process?
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] So LLMs are,
as we've said a couple times now,
LLMs are by definition non-deterministic.
The way in which you make
them more deterministic
is to provide more context.
So the more guardrails and guidelines
and context you can provide,
the more consistent the output you'll get.
So if I say, for instance,
"Generate a web application,"
and that's all I say,
and I ask that five times,
I'm gonna get a React
application, a Python application,
a Rails application, maybe
another React application.
I'm gonna get a lot of variability there.
But if I add context and I say,
"Generate a React application,"
all five times it's gonna generate
a React application for me.
So the point being, the
more context I provide,
the more detail I lay out,
the more deterministic the output will be.
And the challenge with
that is that, historically,
writing the context of
these three spec files
into the prompt every time
I want to do something,
it's not particularly scalable
because the more expansive
I'm trying to build,
the more details there
are and the more gaps
I have to fill when I
generate that prompt.
And I have to rely on every
member of the team to do that,
which is not realistic.
So what we're trying to solve for here
is we're trying to solve for...
Or we're trying to provide
that context upfront.
We're trying to give everybody visibility
into what that context is
and give them the opportunity
to change that context if
they so deem appropriate
before we've gone off and
actually done the work.
But once we have that design file,
once we have those requirements files,
once we've laid out what the tasks are,
once we've coupled that
with our steering files,
we've got a fairly high
deterministic output
in the sense that we've
covered all the gaps,
we've closed a lot of the variables
that the LLM would normally have to go off
and figure out for itself.
So it's still not 100% deterministic.
There's still room for variability.
And that's why we don't want it
to remove the human in the loop.
We don't want Kiro to just take this code
and deploy it into
production sight unseen.
We still wanna do our poll requests,
our code reviews and
those types of things.
But what we are trying to solve for here
is a lot of wasted time reviewing code
that is obviously wrong
because the context
wasn't specified upfront.
And so by doing this work upfront,
we can cut down on the amount
of wasted code generated
and we can improve the likelihood
that a particular poll
request can be approved as is
and merged in.
- [Ryan Bachman] Yeah. And
the other thing I'll say
to that too is the actual
code that's written, right?
If he were to take the spec file,
these requirements, and
blow away all the code
and regenerate it,
it's gonna look different
each time he does it.
But that's implementation details, right?
The requirements stay the same.
How those requirements are satisfied
is strictly implementation details.
And what we're doing here,
I think in essence is abstracting away
the details of the code
and focusing on the business requirements
and acceptance criteria.
'Cause the actual specifics
of the code implementation
while able to change is not as important
as satisfying the requirements.
And that's where you're
gonna see the consistency.
I haven't come to this side of the room,
so I'm gonna start over here
'cause they've been ignored so far.
What you got?
- [Audience Member] How do you share
things like hooks across across projects?
- [Ryan Bachman] Hooks across projects?
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] Hooks across projects
are shared by the fact that
they're checked into the repo.
Oh, sorry, you asked how do
you share them across projects,
not across developers.
So the way in which you
share hooks across projects
at the moment is that you have to copy
that hook into another project.
You take that JSON file
and you copy it into another project.
That's not a particularly
scalable approach.
And we do have some things on the roadmap
and in the pipeline to make
those things more manageable
at the organization level to
be able to push those down
from an administrative level.
But today, in order to
share hooks across projects,
you need to replicate the JSON file
into the appropriate repo.
- [Audience Member] My question
is Kiro ran into some issue.
How reliable is this?
How often do we run into this?
- [Ryan Bachman] How reliable is Kiro?
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] How reliable is Kiro?
Well, normally I would tell
you that it's very reliable.
Now obviously it struggled
on the generation
of that Agent Hook.
The issue with Node I think
is actually a local problem
on my machine, which I will
figure out after this session.
But generally speaking,
Kiro is fairly reliable in the sense
that it has a good
understanding of the source code
and it generates source
code fairly reliably.
You'll also find as in many cases
when it does run into a challenge,
and you could see this
actually in the task
that we completed, it ran
the command and it said,
"Oh, you don't have Node installed."
And so it actually self-corrected there
and it said, "Well, let
me try something else."
And it tried that and
that didn't work either
'cause I don't have NPX
installed either, apparently.
And so then it said,
"All right, well now I'm gonna go
and I'm just gonna generate
the code for you manually.
And so I'm gonna skip that
step and I'm gonna keep going."
And the point that I wanna make there
is that these LLMs are designed
to be helpful by nature.
So they want to produce results for you.
And so given the context that's there,
they're getting increasingly
intelligent in how they work.
And so they're gonna try
a particular strategy
and if that strategy doesn't work,
they're gonna move on
to a different strategy
and they're going to
problem solve along the way.
And so generally speaking,
Kiro is pretty effective
in that regard in saying,
"Hey, this is the approach
that I want to take.
Wait a minute, this approach didn't work.
Let me try a different approach
and see if that solves the problem.
And I'm gonna keep going."
And at any point I can
step in and I can intervene
and I can say, "You know what?
You're right, I forgot to install Node.
So let me pause you right
here and go take care of that
and then pick it back up again
and have you keep going
rather than trying to solve for something
that I obviously know is not right."
So generally speaking,
KIRO is pretty reliable in that sense.
This particular example notwithstanding.
- [Audience Member] So if
I want to make a change
to a requirements document,
do I directly do it in that
document or do I ask Kiro?
If I'm directly making the change,
does Kiro check whether it
will break any other part?
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] Yeah.
So the question there was
if I need to make a change
to the requirements document,
so in this particular
case, we have this spec
and we've actually
started building the code.
So we actually have
already run the first task
in the task list.
So what happens now, as is common in life,
somebody comes back and they say,
"Hey, you know, this requirement change,
we don't want red, we want blue.
And we need to make an adjustment."
What do I do? How do I
actually implement that?
There's two ways you can do that.
You can actually come back into the prompt
and you can say,
"Kiro, I need to make an
adjustment to this spec.
I need to change it from red to blue."
And Kiro will go off and it
will make that change for me.
Or I can change it manually.
I can say, "You know what?
I wanna get the planned date here
and also a planned location."
And if I put that change in
there manually like that,
what I can do is I can hit
the "Refine" button up here.
And when I hit the "Refine" button,
what Kiro does is it actually goes
and it evaluates the
change that I just made
to that requirements document.
And not only is it going
to refresh the requirements document
to make sure that this
is logically consistent
because I only changed it
in one acceptance criteria,
the likelihood is that this is probably
gonna need to be reflected
in a couple different acceptance criteria.
It's also gonna make changes
though to the design.
So in the design document,
we laid out what the models looked like,
what the database tables looked like,
all of those different things.
Well, now we've gone and
added a new attribute,
so we're gonna need to make
an adjustment to that model.
So we need to reflect
these changes downstream.
So we need to make the change
not only in the requirements,
but also in the design document.
And potentially, you
know, what this involves,
if we had gotten far
enough in the task list
that we'd actually implemented
those tables already,
we'd actually written the code for them,
we would then need to create another task
to go in and modify those tables.
And so we wanna reflect that
in the task list as well.
So what Kiro does when we
hit the "Refine" button
is that it says,
"All right, I can see
that you've made a change.
I've gone through and I've
validated the requirements.
Now I'm gonna move on to the design phase
and I'm gonna make the adjustments there,
and I'm gonna carry that downstream.
And if I need to create more tasks
because we've already implemented
this piece of the code,
then I'll add some new tasks."
If we haven't implemented this yet,
then I can just modify
the task and I can say,
"Hey, do it the the new way
when you go and implement it."
So I have a couple of
different strategies there
for how to deal with this.
But generally speaking that's
how you would adjust for that.
You'd make the change.
You can either ask Kiro
to make the change for you
in the prompt or you can do it manually
and then hit the "Refine" button
and let Kiro run it through downstream.
- [Audience Member] In both cases,
Kiro does all these processes?
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] Correct.
And it's gonna trace that downstream.
- [Audience Member] I see that it created
a few architectural diagrams.
Can it understand these backgrounds
if I provide mine for him?
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] Yeah.
So two strategies there.
It created architectural diagrams
in the design document
using ASCII text here.
And so you can provide ASCII text files
that have similar design
diagrams and it can infer those.
You can also just draw a design
document on a whiteboard,
take a picture of it and
upload it as an image file,
and then have it say,
"Go and implement this
architecture diagram
based on this image,"
and it will evaluate the image file,
infer the contents of that image
and go off and actually do the spec
or the implementation based on that.
So you can do it based
on either ASCII text,
those types of implementations,
or you can do it based on an image file
like a PNG or a GIF or
whatever the case may be there.
- [Audience Member] If
I have a Lucid chart?
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] Yeah.
If you have a Lucid chart,
you can do that, most
likely with a screenshot
uploaded of the Lucid
diagram and then use that.
- [Audience Member] I have a question.
You said that a project can
have more than one spec.
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] Correct.
- [Audience Member] How
do you define a spec?
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] What do you mean
"How do you define a spec?"
- [Audience Member] In this
particular example (indistinct).
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] Yep.
- [Audience Member] (indistinct).
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] So I want to say,
"I want to add an authentication layer
to my fitness tracker app to keep track
of which user is doing the activity."
I'm gonna, again, put this into Spec mode.
I'm gonna type in my prompt
here and I'm gonna hit "Go."
And what it's gonna do here
is that it's going to
create another spec for me.
And so...
I've got a couple things running here.
It's gonna go and it's
gonna create another spec.
So the specs here are laid out.
I've got a spec directory and
I've got a subdirectory here
for the fitness activity tracker.
And so that subdirectory
there has my design file,
my requirements file,
and my task file in it.
Now I've kicked it off and
I've asked it to generate
a new spec for my authentication layer.
So now I'm gonna add a new feature
to my existing application.
And so now what it's going to do
is it's going to start
building out a new spec for me.
And it's going to say...
It's actually making changes
to the existing spec for me
'cause I haven't implemented it yet.
If it were to build another spec,
it would just create
another subdirectory there
with three new files, a requirements file,
a design file and a tasks file.
- [Audience Member] My
question is (indistinct).
Requirements for the spec, right?
And how do you maintain best practices?
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] Sure.
The question is around best practices.
What's the best way to think about a spec
or how to treat it?
Generally speaking the way...
And, Ryan, you may have
different opinions on this,
but generally speaking,
the way I treat a spec
is I treat it as a bounded feature.
So in this case an authentication layer.
And that feature has a
specific set of things
that I want to get done.
If those things are not done yet,
so in this case, we've
got a whole lot of tasks
that haven't been implemented
yet, and something changes,
I need to add another field,
I need to change a color,
then it makes sense to go
in and modify that spec.
You know, add that feature, whatever.
If that spec is done,
all the tasks are done,
they're finished and
we've completed that spec,
and now you come to me and you say,
"Hey, I want to add another thing to it.
I wanna make a change."
Generally speaking, what I would do
is create another spec there.
So that spec is done, it's finished,
we're gonna put a bow on it,
we're gonna slide it over to the side,
and now we're gonna create a
new spec for this new thing.
Whether it's a change,
whether it's a new feature,
we're gonna create a new spec.
So I generally try to treat my specs
as kind of contained entities.
So when I've done the work there,
I slide it over, I say, "This is done."
If I need to make any more changes,
I'm gonna create a new spec
and I'm gonna deal with it
there so that I have this
kind of running list of specs.
You, technically, can go back
and modify an existing spec,
even if all the tasks are done.
But I find that that makes it really muddy
to be able to keep track
of the work I've done
and how I've done it and
to manage it that way.
So I don't know if you have any
other thoughts on that, but-
- [Ryan Bachman] No. I
mean, I definitely think
it's more art than it is science.
I mean, there's obviously
gonna be general...
Don't put too much into it, right?
Like, you have to get a sense.
I think what you put into spec
also influences how you
organize around that spec.
While there is
collaboration aspects of it,
I don't think I can divvy up a spec
to three different teams, right?
So think about boundaries
of the way you work,
how you work, and the other,
I think to emphasize your point
is clear exit criteria, right?
Like, it's not an ongoing thing.
It's a defined thing that we know
we have concrete, discrete
acceptance criteria
that we can call done, essentially,
the acceptance of done,
and then ship it before
we create another one.
So they're not long-living,
they're organized around
how we are organized.
And, I mean, I don't know, Fibonacci,
I wouldn't put in more
than, I don't know, 21?
Is 21 Fibonacci.?
I don't know, I'm just
making that number up.
Nothing too big.
- Question?
- Developers?
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] Yeah. What
do you do with the developers
who are using something other than VS Code
and who would rather die
with their VIM application
than migrate to something newer?
It's a fair question and there
isn't a great answer for it.
Q Developer has a number
of different plugins
that can be installed.
We have a JetBrains
plugin for Q Developer.
What we have found though is
trying to maintain plugins
for every conceivable IDE under the sun
is a very complicated
process and you end up
with a lot of leapfrogging
and a lack of parity between them.
So the strategy that we
have generally gone to there
is to recommend the CLI.
So the CLI allows you to do a lot
of these things directly from the terminal
and you can open up a terminal window
in JetBrains or in Eclipse or in VS Code,
the native version of VS
Code or in Visual Studio
and you can do whatever
work you want to do there
and benefit from the generative
AI capabilities there
in the CLI.
And that's generally the strategy
we would we propose there.
And understanding that that's not entirely
the same experience as what you have here,
but it allows you to
keep your preferred IDE
and still get some of those benefits.
- [Audience Member] So
it does come with a CLI?
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] It
does come with a CLI.
Yes?
- [Audience Member] How do you prevent
Kiro from hallucinations?
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] How do you prevent
So hallucinations really
are a product of the model
and how good the model is and
the training data in the model
and then the context that the model has
in responding to the prompt.
The models that we are
using have all been vetted.
Kiro doesn't have a a bring
your own API key strategy to it.
So we have a predefined set of models.
We have support right
now for Sonnet 4.5 and 4.
We have support for Haiku,
and we have support for Opus, yeah.
So those models are there
and we've vetted them
and we've made sure that
they generally understand
the context well.
And then the steering
files and the spec files
add the necessary context.
It doesn't guarantee that
you won't see hallucinations,
but it does reduce the
load fairly substantially.
- [Audience Member] The second part was
are you gonna open it
up for like local LLMs?
- [Ryan Yanchuleff] We
are looking at local LLMs,
but if we do that, they will be defined
the same way we define
our remote LLMs as well.
So there'll be a defined set of LLMs
that you can use that would work there.
All right, I think we
have run out of time here.
But I appreciate everybody coming out.
Hopefully you found this useful.
We didn't succeed in building
a fitness application,
but hopefully you get a sense
for how you would approach that
and walk through that process.
And I will make sure I have
Node installed next time.
Thank you, everybody.
(audience applauding)